no no
cata greets you cristian cásseres with his
brief news now in Spanish
there are second dose vaccines
available for walk-ins at the
convention center people who
have received the first dose of the
modern vaccine at some of the
district centers  of health of southern nevada
and do not yet have an appointment can arrive at
the convention center to request the
official remind the public that
people arriving at the clinic must
have received the first dose of
modern between the dates of January 4 to 9
if you have  any questions
about the second dose vaccination process you
can call the
helpline on 70 27 59 1900
some county leaders seek to
loosen coronavirus restrictions
locally a new proposal led
by the commissioner in berlin that
aims to expand the limits  of
capacity in public meetings to 50% the
commissioner said that
the proposal would depend on the tendency of each case
It would be presented to the governor and the
state command for mitigation against the
coronavirus
and as the saying goes there is no date that is
not met or deadline that is not expired the
anticipated celebration of the super 255
I felt if it stops for this Sunday and all
the excitement of the superbowl will  puts can
be seen on our channel 8 where
the confrontation between the
kansas city chiefs and the
tampa bay buccaneers who will play for the
nfl title will be broadcast.  following and
updating all the game action
on our pages and social networks
the news now in spanish the
national soccer league is allowing each
team in the league to invite four
people from their cities to the superbowl
las vegas' glasses invited
four  residents of the valley to go to the
big game the lucky ones who are
heading to traps are
health sector workers that include
doctors cha  rlín edwin orlando or without
nicolás calica and the nurse same before
balsam congratulations to all of them and
we pass with the temperatures for
our region today is expected to be
a warm and sunny day as well as
temperatures in the high 60s the clouds will
return for the start  next
week despite the fact that
several days of pleasant temperatures
I am cristian cásseres and he highlighted
informative the news side in Spanish
happy friday